yeah yeah I know you did I know you did
but that's
enough that's plenty right
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Gal Gadot hello
she's a box office Blockbuster Factor
you know from films like Wonder Woman
Batman vs Superman The Fast and Furious
franchise and many more you can also
catch your star in the brand new Netflix
spy Thriller Heart of Stone which is set
to begin streaming on August 11th Gaga
welcome to the show hello hello
how are you around spicy food are you at
all nervous going into this I am
extremely nervous I'm I I love food I
like
um like some spice to it but I'm I'm not
strong on spicy food well today you will
be are you ready to get started uh yes
I'm too nervous so let's just uh start
it
[Music]
can you imagine if I would go to the
hottest one I have an eye for it like uh
uh Tom Holland came on here and went for
the last one immediately and we were on
it like Dom she was like Secret Service
taking a bullet like coming outside so
don't worry okay we gotcha
but this first one and you'll start at
the handle yeah the classic chili mix
this one that one right there
smells delish right I'm hungry we're
going for it right
[Music]
see I'm ready
I'm gonna take another one all right
because I'm hungry let's go let's go
crazy and I can with the later one let's
see over
good
so in Heart of Stone you play the role
of an international intelligence agent
Rachel Stone it's a very physical
performance that includes everything
from motorcycle chases to gun battles to
paragliding down dark Mountainside how
did the physicality of this role compare
to some of the other backbreaking
characters that you've played over the
years
oh you know something I feel like from
one movie to the to the other to the
next the bar just keeps on going up and
up and up and every time I feel like
okay this was the most I'm never gonna
be able to then the next movie comes
along and the action is even um more
crazy
um
and at the same time it's also you know
I didn't want this to be another Wonder
Woman film so the whole idea was to
create
um a film that would be grounded and the
action would be raw and dynamic and like
when she gets the hit you feel the pain
with her
um so it's a lot different and we had to
work out and train and prep for months
before even filming this film and it was
awesome it was great
[Music]
I feel the spice but that one I can
definitely handle
with the curry yeah you like it I can
see it
it's not a happy dance I love food
when it's good to me
how did you even start this thing so
[Music]
so Chris is actually here again like
Chris uh where's Chris raise your hands
raise your hand there he is right there
I'm the white polo over there so uh
Celebrity Guess is often in like a PR
driven flight pattern when they're doing
media like what can we do to disrupt
that you know and then Chris was like
well what if we had the meat
increasingly spicy chicken wings over
the course of the interview as a way to
break them down and I was like you're a
genius and that was like here's a Jamie
or it's the best thing yeah how can we
break our guests right and look at how
he's at a safe distance he's nowhere
near These Wings you know what I'm
saying you know I'm just like a
sacrificial lamb and all yes but that
was eight years ago and over 300
episodes and this is here we are on the
21st season oh that's amazing yeah so
it's just the dumb idea so you guys are
fire like our daughter knows about this
this is like this we still got the kids
you have the Next Generation no but you
have like us but also the next
generation is pretty amazing thank you
thank you I really appreciate it yeah
always okay lemon pepper
just so you know I got some tips from
Friends what were the tips
um try not to touch the lips breathe
breathe like this oh you you gotta kick
over space I'm not doing really I'm no
superhero all right I'm No Wonder Woman
do this Ali Abbott who's with me
she's in the cast of Heart of Stone
she's Indian I ask her are you good
within like how are you doing with spicy
food she was like I travel around the
world with like a bottle of spicy sauce
so she said breathe like this
[Music]
just like that that if I do this
it's not good it's just like like a fire
engine yeah that makes sense to me
another one no no let me move on
are you finished at home you know what I
beat you to it I beat you to it I'm just
showing off over here
pound for pound what's the fight
sequence or battle scene that made your
jaw drop the most when you saw it for
the first time on the Silver Screen
um Wonder Woman I must say that when I
was watching the the second Wonder Woman
and it starts with this sequence of
Young Wonder Woman fighting all of the I
got so emotional it was like me seeing
as me being a eight-year-old girl
watching like an amazing girl doing
amazing things that was emotionally uh
effective on me
thank you
smoked garlic raw sugar and ginger fruit
wow
[Music]
it comes and goes that's the thing it
comes in waves that's what we're at
we're on like a little bit of a wave
here we're on a little bit of a wave I'm
fine I can see it I can see it you
you're are you okay you know 300
episodes yeah you know what I'm saying
those City miles yeah you know what I'm
saying
okay and now it's gonna be like the this
big of a jump from one chicken to the
next one I'm gonna be so honest with you
this entire way this entire way so that
was a little bit of a hot four we call
that one like I have four a little bit
of a hot four okay five I think will go
down a little bit and that's and then
I'll I'll clue you into each one as we
go all right we're in a good spot we're
in a good spot you're almost halfway
there and you're doing great okay you
know all the talk shows I don't know in
Israel at least they have these games
like a TV games that you can play yeah
yeah yeah like on a million dollars and
then if it's never mind it's like that
they have like eight questions and if
they answer all eight they get a million
whatever uh-huh I feel like I'm in a
game yeah that's interesting you know
like will you give me a million bucks
take a look at the studio take a look at
the studio you think we got a million
bucks but maybe that's why you know
because you're so generous
okay
so easy too easy two oh okay I'll
remember you said that
okay ready I'm ready okay
[Music]
small game
and slow release
we have that cumulative effect going you
know
where five adds to four which added to
three two you know
all right
it's happening it's happening
what's the most Bonkers car stunt that
you've ever seen with your own eyes or
heard about second hand on a fast and
furious set
when we were filming we were filming in
one of the Canary Islands and they shut
the roads there and they literally sat a
huge truck and a bunch of very expensive
cars on fire during the day it was just
like a like you do with a match yeah box
Fast and Furious every set piece that
they have with the cars trains Rockets
airplanes all these different vehicles
are in insane it's crazy it's crazy it's
uh are you good every new experience I
just try to survive it just the same as
everyone else you know what I mean I
don't know how Chris bit Chris right yes
how are you like you don't even
alternate
why have you done right now but yeah why
isn't there like a bullpen or something
you don't care about people you're not
interested in people like that just a
few years talented and you get the heat
literally for it I'm uh I'm a chicken
wing garbage disposal it's like 50 50.
like I don't know I should check out his
paperwork who knows who knows
okay
it smells delish though
that was weird that was good was it no
oh no it was a nice big bite
right this is a different world
I know I know I know
I know I know how it goes I know how it
goes
I know and then this is be careful
around your eyes you know like don't
touch
those eyes it's too late
my tongue is sweating I know I know I
can see it I can see it
I'm so hot
oh my God
wow okay okay
nope you know something no problem it's
it's a journey that's right it's all
about this you know the problem that
whatever they do it's a journey yes a
journey through the spicy wings through
the it's a spicy Journey it's uh
yeah
it's like when I work out and it's leg
day yeah yeah it's leg day so I always
do this uh I hate it
but actually
I should say I love it and release the
11s right and just go for it I love
spicy exactly spicy is the [__] exactly
and you know what it's that it's the
pain in the legs that your legs getting
stronger you know like the pain
everything I'm killing all of my taste
but
all at once
wow it's really like
non-stop yeah this one is good like he's
evil
[Music]
I'm not following you I'm just going for
it by myself here we go
I don't know maybe it's because I'm
already burnt right
um for anything that we're just in the
we're just in the Wild and Free over
here I'm like after a numb
you nabbed my tongue right
on leg day
my tongue is so sweaty
it doesn't it's like dilutes all the
spicy from the chicken yeah but here's
what I will say uh it was what happens
with hot food is sometimes you bite into
it you think you're doing good and then
one of those waves kind of hits but it
looks like the water's crashing against
the shore and you're doing just fine
over here gal and this is number what
one you are all the way up to seven
you're doing so good you're doing so
good cat two me in the hospital like
something happened to my stomach they're
trying to figure out why there's holes
everywhere in my digestive system okay
so someone who's the founding member of
a mac and cheese brand shout out to
Google's what do you think is the key to
a perfect bowl of mac and cheese in your
opinion
a good Bowl mac and cheese is one that
is Rich creamy that every bite while you
is melting in your mouth and you're just
craving to go to the next bite that it's
salty but it also has a touch of
sweetness to it I'm there right with you
I'm there right with you how did we not
bring a bowl of mac and cheese
you poor thing you've done it 300 times
and I know what it is and I know what it
means and I know it's about to happen
okay
I feel like I'm eating death that's
exactly what it is
no we're probably plenty but you let me
know
it doesn't stop and this is gonna grow
from here too
you know what I have to say
in my eight years of doing this show
I don't feel like I've ever had a guest
so perfect in their non-verbal
communication as you
[Music]
I
how we feeling okay okay
I'm just interpreting
this abstract dance over here oh careful
careful around the eyes careful around
the eyes yeah there we go that's better
that's better that's better
[Music]
is there an underrated Israeli snack
that you think more Americans should
know about like something that you think
has real mainstream crossover potential
what I know I know it's crazy I get it I
get it to come out the other side I get
it I get it and you've done it 300 times
yeah that's awesome particular believe
it or not and probably like more just
from like sort of like ancillary like
shoulder things that I've done over the
years you know what I mean like I've
been here and what you're going through
I've been here
right all around does everything stop I
know I know it doesn't stop it doesn't
stop
it's like you know how it felt how did
it feel how did it feel it's one point
yeah yeah no that's yeah we made an
interview show it's hard to talk I get
it
remember Harry Potter when it comes to
and he sucks the life out of him yeah
yeah like that right but it's just suck
the life
it's like what is happening and you
can't stop it's still going no I know I
know you know and like when you went for
the ears that was interesting to me
because uh yeah I used to there's a
there's a guy named Chili Klaus who's
also like a spicy pepper eater in like
the YouTube space and one time we ate a
Carolina
[Music]
as one does
and one time we the Carolina Reaper the
hottest pepper in the world and he would
snap
to remind himself that he's not going
deaf yeah I don't know why I did it
um there is a delicious wafer
yeah yeah yeah that's my
um
there is I'm trying to think about stuff
that you don't actually have here like
we do
and there's not much there's not much
you guys are doing pretty good on snacks
I must tell you you know and uh in hot
sauce too maybe there's like something
yeah yeah yeah or maybe not let's leave
it here you enjoy it Israel is enough
going on you know
uh okay [__] it let's do it okay [__] it
let's do it
[Music]
no not fun you know by any stretch of
the imagination but
it's got that watermelon it's kind of
refreshing up front kick back right
right right I get it
with me
okay
so in 2004 you won Miss Israel even
though I know that it was far from your
focus at the time was there anything
that surprised you most about the behind
the scenes of a beauty pageant you know
like Savage gamesmanship backstage or
like ways to Ace certain categories wow
so when I went to Miss Israel in Israel
to begin with I went for the experience
and so I can tell my grandkids that
Grandma was blah blah blah and then I
won and it was shocking I never meant to
win I came for fun and all of the sudden
I felt it's funny you're 18 you're
taking things very
you know uh seriously the only part that
I enjoyed doing was like the the opening
sequence with the dance oh I can tell I
can see it and yeah I've been seeing it
in y'all afternoon that I could not you
know you can take the girl out of the
city you can't take this so um yeah that
was my experience with um yeah you want
to go for the Apollo you saw you saw it
right away why are you shaking it
we really going for it we're going okay
just tell me what to do what to expect
Glory Glory because it'll all be over
the whole thing will be behind you and
you will have reached the top of the
mountain
maybe when my daughter watches it she'll
be so proud proud so proud and you'll be
like and I just do it for Alma and Maya
really for the girls
yeah okay
is it delicious it actually is kind of
good to be honest with you it's very hot
but
I just got a reminder a reminder from
the bum
um okay just a tiny tiny one yeah
perfect perfect
oh that's intense
your name there's a locked in gal I'm
locked in let's see who's gonna bring
first this is nothing dude
no problem
you blinked
[Laughter]
that's right I have a lot of practice
and what we're gonna do is put your
dialogue exercises to the test here to
close things out all right do you have
a favorite tongue twister vocal warm-up
and if so can we try it with our tongues
and mouths on fire yeah finding it
do you want to do a Hebrew one yeah
that'll be easy for me
one more time
[Music]
you're so good wow well you know what no
gal Hebrew you are so just like that
taking on the wings of death and living
to tell the tale and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you this camera this
on in your life
[Music]
what do you mean
oh oh why we're here everybody this is
Gal Gadot please enjoy no let me do it
again I can't even think
it's a miracle I speak English right now
take two
hey everyone that was me Gal Gadot I
hope you enjoy Heart of Stone coming out
on August 11th on Netflix
that was nice I mean nice that was like
a journey that was an experience
the fact that you've been doing this for
eight years
is incredible and it is so unique you
like cracked an angle on how that also
you get so
like there's no masks
what's real you get all the real
spicy is the [__]
thank you so much for watching today's
video I have a very exciting new product
alert last year hot ones brought the
heat to the freezer aisle with our first
ever hot ones boneless chicken bites
well now we are bringing even more heat
to the freezer aisle with our brand new
hot ones chicken strips made with our
first ever seasoned blend two boldly
seasoned varieties you have the spicy
garlic featuring The Classic garlic
Fresno with mild heat and garlic blasted
goodness and Smoky habanero with the
tropical medium spice of our Los
Calientes Rojo we took the sauces that
you know and love and with a little
kitchen magic turned it into the perfect
season blend that go great on our new
hot ones chicken strips to find hot ones
chicken strips near you visit
hotoneschallenge.com that's
hotwingschallenge.com snack em dip them
make them the perfect party platter
thank you
[Music]